pennsylvania senator bob casey democrat
um senator very good to have you back
i'm wondering how this battle back and
forth on the state's
senator and the counts and all of that
is affecting or could affect
what's going on in this georgia runoff
race two runoff races what do you think
well neil i think the the georgia
elections on on the fifth of january
obviously i think stand on their own um
the the the result
uh the the presidential race is going to
be
certified soon as your correspondent
indicated
the pennsylvania results will be
certified on the 23rd
but of course there's a lot at stake in
the georgia races because if
if our side is able to win both it'll be
a 50-50 tie and
we would then have a majority because of
the
the vice president so that that's that's
a significant fight and it's going to be
uh
weeks of of battle but i think our side
has a really strong foundation now that
joe biden was declared the winner
in georgia you know
we have not called that race in georgia
ourselves others have not but you're
quite right i mean he leads in all of
these various accounts but
having said that uh senator i am curious
about what joe biden wants you to know
each other obviously very well we're
going to send it together and all of
that i'm just curious as to what you
make
of um what happens uh
if you don't take the senate uh that the
that
you lose both of these seats that is
democrats or you split which again
wouldn't be good you need to win them
both
um some argue that joe biden actually
prefers that right now because he
doesn't want to cave
to some of the progressives in your
party many of whom are demanding that
uh you know you get bernie sanders in
there as labor secretary elizabeth
warren as treasury secretary and he
doesn't want to go that route
what do you think of that well neil
i think that certainly democratic
senators and
president-elect biden want a democratic
senate i don't think there's any
question about that
now he hasn't told me that but that's i
know him well enough to say that
but i think if it doesn't go in our
direction
and if if it is a a continuation of the
republican majority
we're going to have to get a lot done
the two biggest crises in the lives of
most people
are what you've been covering this
morning the the virus this raging virus
which is
hitting a record number of cases every
day
here in pennsylvania the cases are way
up we've set daily records as well
we got more than 9 200 people dead
in our state and it's so it's raging
everywhere north and south east and west
so that challenge is in front of us and
there's
it's a challenge both parties must
confront and then the jobs crisis the
economic crisis we got more than
half a million people out of work in
september 518 000 so
we need a job strategy as well and i
think that's true of both parties so
we're all going to have to work together
on these two crises i would not want to
be a senator
who's standing in the way of dealing
with those two crises
let me ask you about that you are
senator right now from pennsylvania very
influential one and and we heard from
the uh
president-elect's health care task force
uh dr michael osterholm who raised the
possibility
of a four to six week lockdown um
joe biden himself has not endorsed that
and nor has he rejected it
how do you feel about that a four to six
week lockdown mandated a federal
government
well neil i don't think that's uh likely
to happen number one number two
is the the reason i can say that is
because we know a lot more about the
virus than we did before even though the
case numbers are higher than they were
in april in a lot of places
and it is raging uh we know a lot more
about how to deal with it
look if if tens of millions of more
americans were wearing masks
that alone would would uh turn this in
the right direction so
i think the master do you think the mask
mandate is in order
senator you think of mass commanding is
in order even the governor north dakota
is kicking that around
go ahead personally i think that's
that's going to be necessary in some
places
but it should require a mandate um if if
you're a patriotic american
you care about your neighbor the person
next to you
and you care about your own health or
the health of someone in your household
you should wear a mask the good news is
most people are wearing masks
and they understand how valuable that is
to
to turning this in the right direction
but i think i think we know a lot more
about how to control this virus but
we need a strategy on testing there's
still not nearly enough
testing we've got to get faster results
on testing we need more personal
protective equipment all of this
is playing out in a in large measure in
nursing homes neal you know that more
than 91 000 people
have died in nursing homes when you add
up the residents who died in the workers
we got to turn that in the right
direction i think we can